France 24 et RFI présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'Europe nous sommes sur France
24 et Radio France Internationale pour
recevoir notre grande invité alors que
l'Europe s'enfonce dans la morosité la
vie chère avec une guerre en Ukraine
meurtrière à ses portes nous recevons
aujourd'hui Raphaël Glucksmann élu
député européen en 2019 comme chef de
fil du mouvement place publique et des
socialistes vous êtes aujourd'hui
bonjour monsieur Glucksmann en duplex
avec nous ranger chez les socialistes et
démocrates au Parlement européen mais
surtout vous présidez la fameuse
commission au nom a rallonge
commission sur l'ingérence étrangère
dans l'ensemble des processus
démocratiques de l'Union européenne y
compris la désinformation vous rendez
compte en fait de certaines de vos
conclusions dans votre dernier ouvrage
la grande confrontation comment Poutine
a fait la guerre à nos démocraties aux
éditions à Larry alors vous estimez que
les Européens subissent depuis au moins
deux décennies une guerre hybride du
Kremlin est-ce que on a été intoxiqué à
la propagande russe nous avons été
intoxiqués nous avons été corrompus
aussi nous avons été naïfs enfin vous
savez moi ça fait trois ans qu'elle a la
tête de cette commission spéciale du
Parlement européen je
dissecte j'enquête j'analyse sur les
entreprises de déstabilisation de nos
démocraties par des régimes étrangers
aucun régime étranger n'a eu une telle
entreprise de déstabilisation de
démocraties que le régime russe je parle
là d'attaque cyber sur nos hôpitaux par
exemple l'hôpital de Corbeil-Essonnes
avec des médecins qui ne peuvent plus
soigner les patients je parle de
campagne de déstabilisation de notre
débat public avec notamment les fermes
atrol et à bottes de prix gojin et de
l'Internet resears agency de
Saint-Pétersbourg je parle aussi et bien
de la corruption de dirigeants européens
qui vont prendre des décisions
stratégiques d'une importance immense et
travailler pour les principaux
bénéficiaires de ces décisions
stratégiques c'est-à-dire les acteurs
clés du régime russe et donc il y a une
entreprise si vous voulez multifacettes
d'attaque contre nos démocraties et
pendant très longtemps pendant de trop
longues années nos dirigeants n'ont pas
simplement sacrifier nos principes dans
leur relation avec Vladimir Poutine ils
n'ont pas simplement sacrifié les
tchétchen les Géorgiens les Ukrainiens
ou les Syriens ils ont sacrifié notre
propre souveraineté dans votre ouvrage
vous parlais plusieurs dirigeants
européens dont l'ex chancelier Gerard
Schroeder ou même François Fillon en
France recasé au conseil
d'administration d'entreprise russe il
faudrait pouvoir les mettre en prison
peut-être pour conflit d'intérêt
il faut leur interdire quand vous avez
servi si vous voulez au plus haut niveau
nos états vous ne pouvez pas ensuite
aller travailler pour des intérêts
hostiles à nos cités à nos démocraties à
nos nations quand vous avez été
chancelier de l'Allemagne que vous avez
fait en sorte que l'Allemagne quitte
abandonne le nucléaire que vous avez
créé la dépendance de l'Allemagne au gaz
russe que vous avez construit lancé la
construction du plus grand gazoduc
sous-marin du monde Nord Stream qui
relie la Russie à l'Allemagne vous ne
pouvez pas dans la foulée de votre
défaite aux élections partir travailler
pour Gazprom et mettre vos réseaux vos
connaissances de votre état au service
d'un intérêt étranger et donc il s'agit
de Schroeder en Allemagne mais les
Russes ont inventé un terme à partir de
leur expérience avec garage favorisation
de la classe politique européenne c'est
à dire la transformation de notre
politique en un marché et si vous voulez
ou les puissances étrangères peuvent
venir faire leurs courses il faut mettre
le ola assez pratique vous êtes plutôt
opposés à la stratégie de sanctions
progressive et d'oser qui a été adopté
par la Commission européenne qui nous
permet de faire mal aux Russes sans
couler notre économie parce que c'était
un petit peu l'idée vous dites ce
qu'elle a empêché la victoire de
l'Ukraine les sanctions sont
progressives mais elles sont
incohérentes si vous voulez vraiment
heurter les intérêts du régime russe
alors vous devez mettre fin aux
exemptions sectorielles je prends par
exemple l'exemple des diamants pourquoi
est-ce que les diamants sont exclus des
sanctions européennes les diamants
l'importation des diamants russes je
veux dire si demain et bien les diamants
viennent à manquer au marché d'Anvers je
ne crois pas qu'il y aura des émeutes de
la fin en Europe parce que les diamants
ne sont pas un bien de consommation de
première nécessité et donc il y a des
intérêts établis qui font pression pour
édulcorer l'impact de nos sanctions mais
l'attitude progressive de l'Union
européenne elle est surtout nuisible pas
sur les sanctions mais sur l'aide à
portée à l'Ukraine et c'est ça qui
heurte nos intérêts sur le terrain parce
que notre intérêt est que l'Ukraine
gagne cette guerre pourquoi pas
simplement parce que nous sommes
solidaires des Ukrainiens pas simplement
par humanisme ou pas simplement parce
qu'une démocratie est agressée mais
parce que la résistance ukrainienne au
moment où on se parle c'est notre
première ligne de défense ou en
serions-nous aujourd'hui si quand le
président Biden propose l'exfiltration
au président zeninski au premier jour de
la guerre et bien le président zalinski
n'avait pas répondu nous avons besoin je
n'ai pas besoin de taxi j'ai besoin de
munitions nous serions dans une
situation
sécuritaire catastrophique et les
questions que nous nous posons
aujourd'hui c'est ce sont celles de la
défense de la Pologne et de la Lituanie
nous avons perdu des mois et des mois à
hésiter sur la question de l'artillerie
des mois et des mois à relancer la
production de munitions des mois et des
mois ensuite à discuter des tanks et
bien désormais il faut avoir une
approche beaucoup plus compréhensive et
comprendre que si nous voulons que la
Russie perd cette guerre et c'est notre
intérêt stratégique et bien nous devons
nous mettre au travail de manière
beaucoup plus efficace quand le
président Emmanuel Macron en juillet
2022 parle d'économie de guerre c'est
juste c'est ce qu'il faut dire mais
derrière il n'y a rien qui est fait
c'est ça le problème ça fait des mois et
on ne produit toujours pas les munitions
nécessaires pour que l'Ukraine puisse
résister à l'offensive russe quand vous
dites l'Ukraine peut gagner dans quelles
conditions sur quel territoire qu'est-ce
que vous voyez comme sortie de guerre
acceptable finalement l'Ukraine doit
retrouver sa souveraineté sur les
frontières de 1991 reconnu par le droit
international et garantit par les
puissances européennes et
occidental peut-être que tout cela se
terminera par des négociations peut-être
que les soldats Ukrainiens n'auront pas
à libérer l'ensemble du territoire mais
ils doivent aujourd'hui être en position
dominante sur le terrain c'est la seule
manière d'obliger le régime russe à
stopper sa guerre je rappelle que en
fait on parle là de la mise à bas de
l'architecture de sécurité en Europe
jusqu'à l'annexion de la Crimée depuis
la fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale
aucun État n'avait annexé des
territoires de ses voisins et c'était la
base qui permettait à l'Europe de vivre
en paix même pendant la guerre froide
même pendant la guerre froide quand au
plus haut point de tension entre
l'Occident et l'Union soviétique et bien
c'était un tabou qui n'était pas brisé
mercredi dernier les présidents de la
Commission du Parlement européen et ceux
de la radar le donc le Parlement
ukrainien ont tenu leur première réunion
conjointe la perspective d'adhésion au
club européen donné à ce pays en guerre
pour vous c'est très important ou c'est
un gadget non c'est pas un gadget quand
vous êtes plongé dans la nuit noire de
la guerre que vous avez face à une armée
qui commet des crimes de guerre
innommable et multiples et bien vous
avez besoin d'un horizon et l'horizon de
l'adhésion à l'Union européenne est un
horizon fondamental pour l'Ukraine vous
savez on a souvent dit que le drapeau
européen bleu étoilé et bien ne charrier
absolument aucun une forme d'attachement
émotionnelle parce que personne n'était
jamais mort pour lui et bien il y a des
gens qui meurent chaque jour en Ukraine
pour tous les principes qui sont
incarnés dans ce drapeau finalement ce
que font les Ukrainiens au-delà d'être
la première ligne de défense de nos
sociétés c'est de nous redonner foi dans
les principes même de la construction
européenne c'est de nous réapprendre que
la démocratie n'est pas simplement
faible et que nos sociétés ouvertes
peuvent mériter qu'on se batte pour elle
finalement il nous réapprenne à dire et
à aimer ce que nous sommes et donc ils
vont faire du bien à l'Union européenne
lorsqu'ils seront intégrés dans l'Union
européenne et encore une fois moi là je
me place pas là du point de vue de la
morale je me place du point de vue de
nos intérêts stratégiques notre intérêt
stratégique à long terme c'est la
victoire des Ukrainiens et leur
intégration à l'Union européenne vous
parlez aussi d'ingérence de la Russie
qui attaque par par effectivement
guerhybride nous démocratie est-ce que
vous craignez qu'elle cherche à
intervenir dans les élections évidemment
nationales mais surtout européenne de
l'an prochain par exemple en fait il n'y
a pas une élection majeure sur notre
continent sans qu'il y ait une ingérence
ça peut prendre la forme de cyber sur la
campagne présidentielle par exemple en
2017 d'Emmanuel Macron dans le brexit
dans la campagne Brésil ça peut prendre
la forme de financement
occulte ça peut aussi prendre une forme
qui est celle de la participation au
débat public en faisant monter les
opinions les plus extrêmes possibles
quitte à être profondément
contradictoire par exemple il
soutiennent les trolls russes aussi bien
les indépendantistes catalans que les
ultra-nationalistes espagnols une des
responsabilités principales de notre
commission c'est de préparer par exemple
les élections européennes de 2024 et
nous savons qu'il y aura des attaques
simplement il faut qu'on se prépare
qu'on ait une harmonisation de l'espace
public européen des législations qui
visent à défendre notre démocratie et de
faire en sorte que si vous voulez les
décisions qui sont prises à Moscou ou à
Pékin ne viennent pas impacter celles
qui sont prises en Europe c'est Manuel
Macron a assumé ce qu'il avait déclaré à
propos de Taïwan être allié des
États-Unis ne signifie pas être vassal
dit-il c'est pas parce qu'on est un
allié qu'on a plus le droit de tout seul
il a été pour cela très critiqué
notamment par nos alliés allemands et
polonais et vous bien sûr qu'être allié
ne signifie pas être vassal et il a
raison de vouloir l'autonomie
stratégique européenne mais l'autonomie
stratégique européenne ça se construit
avec les Européens or dans l'avion qui
leur ramène de Pékin et bien Emmanuel
Macron a assumé des propos qui ne sont
pas les propos qui font consensus en
Europe et qui sont la position
européenne la position européenne elle
avait été assumée par Ursula anderline
qui avait une attitude beaucoup plus
dure et ferme vis-à-vis de la tyrannie
chinoise et donc Emmanuel Macron il a
raison sur l'objectif de l'autonomie
stratégique organique il faut une
défense européenne on ne peut pas être
simplement des consommateurs de la
sécurité américaine on peut pas dépendre
des élections tous les quatre ans aux
États-Unis dans le Michigan ou dans le
viscontin pour savoir si nous serons
protégés et défendus donc une attitude
responsable c'est de construire cette
défense européenne et de construire
l'autonomie stratégique européenne mais
pour que cela arrive il va falloir que
Paris arrête de penser qu'une relation
privilégiée avec Moscou ou une relation
privilégiée avec Pékin c'est plus
important qu'une relation privilégiée
avec Vilnius avec Varsovie ou avec
Bruxelles et et c'est là le cœur de cela
si on veut être crédible dans notre la
parole que l'on porte et moi je la porte
au Parlement européen quotidiennement
sur l'autonomie stratégique sur la
nécessité de faire une défense sur la
nécessité de faire un bail européen acte
de réserver les marchés militaires aux
productions européennes et bien il va
falloir montrer qu'on est sensible aux
intérêts stratégiques vitaux des autres
pays européens
au passage qui sont tous dans l'OTAN et
qui en tout cas en matière de défense
pure bien dépendre de cette alliance
alliance Atlantique bien plus que
évidemment de leur appartenance a lieu
bien sûr mais ils sont prêts à
comprendre nos partenaires que la
situation aux États-Unis est très
instable et que aujourd'hui si nous
avions Donald Trump à la tête des
États-Unis et bien que ferions-nous face
à de l'Ukraine et aux menaces qui pèsent
sur la sécurité européenne nous ne
serions pas aujourd'hui dans la même
situation donc ils sont prêts à entendre
que nous devons construire une défense
commune ils sont prêts à entendre que
nous devons renforcer l'industrie de la
défense en Europe mais pour pouvoir
entendre cela il faut aussi que Paris
mais Berlin de la même manière
reconnaissent leurs
erreurs leurs erreurs stratégiques
reconnaissent le fait qu'ils n'ont pas
écouté les alertes qui venaient de
Tallinn de Vilnius ou de Varsovie sur
les menaces qui pèsent sur nous de la
part du régime de Poutine que nous avons
traité avec le mépris l'Europe centrale
et orientale pendant toutes ces années
il faut le dire et ensuite il faut agir
en conséquence hors quand il prend sa
position sur Taïwan quand il est bien
explique que ce n'est pas finalement
l'intérêt vital de la France à ce
moment-là ni de l'Europe il ne parle pas
en tant qu'Européen il parle en tant
qu'Emmanuel Macron et ensuite nous au
Parlement dans les institutions
européennes
nous devons sortir les rames pour
expliquer que dans l'autonomie
stratégique c'est pas simplement une
embardée entre Paris et Pékin que c'est
quelque chose de plus profond et
comprend en compte les intérêts des
autres Européens et donc là il fait
perdre finalement un temps fou à
l'agenda qui est censé être le sien et
qui a un agenda juste l'autonomie
stratégique c'est pas simplement ce
définir en indépendance vis-à-vis des
États-Unis c'est aussi ausculter
l'ensemble de nos chaînes de production
comprendre que finalement aujourd'hui
nous en sommes réduits à être totalement
dépendant du régime communiste chinois
pour pouvoir pour notre secteur
stratégique par exemple nous votons des
crédits illimités et nous avons raison
de le faire pour la transition
énergétique mais aujourd'hui ce sont des
subventions à l'appareil productif
chinois parce que qui produit nos
panneaux photovoltaïques ou nos
éoliennes et donc il va falloir qu'on
rapatrie chez nous des secteurs
stratégiques qu'on rompe avec avec une
stratégie de libre-échange généralisée
qui nous a rendu totalement dépendant
d'un régime dont le principe est au
stylonaute et dont les intérêts sont
contradictoires avec les nôtres alors le
président français qui se veut leader
sur la scène
europérée contestée dans son pays sur la
réforme des retraites il ne veut rien
lâcher vous comprenez pourquoi Raphaël
Glucksman non je ne comprends pas
pourquoi et je ne comprends pas pourquoi
dans un moment d'extrême tension au
moment où l'Europe est en guerre au
moment où l'inflation heurte de plein
fouet les classes les plus populaires de
notre pays il a décidé de scinder la
France autour de cette réforme injuste
ce n'était ni la bonne réforme ni le bon
moment pour la faire et donc je ne
comprends pas non plus pourquoi quand il
parle en visite officielle en Chine dans
une visite aussi périlleuse et bien il
décide à son arrivée à Pékin de cibler
la CFDT et Laurent Berger je veux dire
qu'est-ce qu'il cherche il cherche la
montée des tensions dans notre pays la
scission
le trouble c'est précisément le moment
où on devrait avoir des dirigeants qui
n'ont le souci que de unifier notre pays
autour d'un horizon mobilisateur et
c'est pas simplement une lubie si vous
voulez de dire que c'est le moment de la
justice sociale et de la solidarité dans
nos pays c'est le souci de l'efficacité
c'est le réalisme qui devrait nous
conduire à ça nous sommes dans une
situation de guerre il y a des profits
de guerre donc au lieu de focaliser
l'attention sur une réforme injuste et
bien la France aurait dû prendre la tête
d'une croisade contre les pros les super
profits de guerre de d'une répartition
plus juste des richesses et c'est
précisément le contraire qui a été fait
et je pense que c'est la mauvaise
réforme au mauvais moment défendu de la
mauvaise manière et qu'il y avait
infiniment mieux à faire pour la France
Merci Raphaël Glucksman d'avoir été
notre invité aujourd'hui merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis sur France 24 sur RFI
restez bien sûr en ce qui vous concerne
en notre compagnie tout de suite nous
prenons la direction de Bruxelles pour
notre grand débat avec des euros députés
et ma conso de Public Sénat Marie
Brémond
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre depuis le
Parlement européen à Bruxelles pour
parler d'une intelligence inhumaine qui
nous envahit et inquiète une
intelligence artificielle qui génère des
images plus vrai que nature comme celle
d'Emmanuel Macron qui ramasse les
poubelles de Donald Trump qui se fait
arrêter ou encore le pape François vêtu
d'une doudoune blanche ces photos
trafiquées en ont le plus d'un car leur
trucage est quasi un détectable oui et
le nouveau système conversationnel chat
GPT fait fureur dans le monde entier
révolutionne le monde numérique il est
capable de répondre clairement dans
plusieurs langues à des questions
complexes d'écrire des sonnets ou encore
de rédiger un article scientifique mais
il présente aussi des dangers l'Italie a
d'ailleurs interdit pour infraction à la
protection des données ce système à les
enseignants craignent que leurs élèves
l'utilisent pour tricher les décideurs
politiques redoutent surtout qu'ils
puissent servir à la désinformation de
masse l'intelligence artificielle c'est
récemment illustrée comme un nouvel
outil de la propagande de l'extrême
droite en Allemagne mettant en scène par
exemple des ordres de migrants fictives
et l'Union européenne quant à elle
travaille depuis des années un projet de
règlement sur l'intelligence
artificielle qui serait la première
législation d'envergure au monde pour
encadrer le secteur objectif placer le
vieux continent en tête de la course à
l'innovation tout en garantissant la
sécurité et les droits des utilisateurs
alors nous en parlons avec Karen
Melchior bonjour vous êtes heureux
député danoises du groupe Renou au
centre donc de l'hémicycle et David
Corman bonjour merci d'être avec vous
député européen français les Verts alors
est-ce qu'il faut se réjouir pour vous
ou avoir peur de cette intelligence
artificielle et de sa révolution
de poser la question et plus compliquée
que ça d'abord vous le savez ce qu'on
dit souvent des innovations c'est que ce
qui compte c'est ce qu'on en fait une
innovation c'est par un progrès en soi
c'est le choix démocratique des donner
des citoyens qui décident de ces usages
qui décident des technologies qu'on
tolèrent ou pas des interactions
qu'elles peuvent avoir sur un certain
nombre de droits fondamentaux vous savez
parler des aspects démocratiques mais
nos droits privés le droit des
consommateurs etc etc c'est ces
réflexions là qu'il faut avoir donc en
avoir peur ça sera une attitude un peu
infantile sans réjouir ça serait une
attitude un peu
un peu naïve donc il faut faire preuve
de maturité par rapport à une
technologie qui
on va en parler mais de mon point de vue
pose un certain nombre de problèmes et
parmi tous les problèmes qu'elle pose
elle favorise une concentration des
pouvoirs et notamment des pouvoirs
économiques et des pouvoirs de
prescription économique à un niveau
qu'on a jamais connu c'est ce qu'on voit
aux Etats-Unis avec les gafams c'est ce
qu'on voit aussi avec la Chine avec un
autre modèle est-ce que vous pensez
comme une ALM musk et des centaines
d'experts qu'il faut mettre intelligence
artificielle sur pause pendant six mois
pour élaborer de meilleurs garde-fous
pour ces logiciels juger dangereux pour
l'humanité est-ce qu'il faut mettre
l'intelligence artificielle sur pause
non il faut pas mettre le développement
des articles de l'intelligence
artificielle en pause il faut avoir une
régulation des
usages de cette technique et les
technologies c'est ça qu'on avait
travaillé dessus pendant plusieurs
années au Parlement en disant qu'il y a
certains
usages qui sont qui sont interdits il y
a un certain usages qui sont au risque
où il faut où on a des demandes des
utilisateurs des développeurs de ces
techniques qu'il doit mettre des des
gardes en place pour l'utilisation je
trouve que cette lettre qui ont été
signée qui est en initiés par une signée
par Elon Musk et des experts
ça montre que c'est bien que nous sommes
déjà de travailler dessus il faudra
aussi inclure par exemple le chat du
petit cette technologie donc qui est
inclus dans les lettres aussi sur les
régulations c'est qu'on est en train de
faire au Parlement mais c'est
l'utilisation quand même chez Corman
avait dit et pas la technique elle-même
donc il faut regarder oui alors parce
que vous parliez de fantasme mon âge un
peu en pleine science-fiction les
ordinateurs qui prennent le contrôle
comme dans Matrix mais en attendant en
Allemagne quand on regarde ce qui se
passe d'ores et déjà bien par exemple
l'extrême droite de l'AFD a commencé à
faire passer
à faire un usage régulier à des fins de
propagande de cette intelligence
artificielle en générant des images
antimigrants et climato-sceptiques qui
n'existent pas et ça c'est pas dans
l'exemple que vous donnez c'est pas
l'ordinateur qui prend le contrôle c'est
bien des humains qui utilisent cette
technologie à des fins de propagande
est-ce que ça révèle c'est que en
réalité
et ça c'est tout ce qu'on est en train
de vivre avec vous savez l'essor du
complotisme c'est que les gens ont envie
de croire à quelque chose et vous pouvez
marquer en rouge moi je pense qu'il faut
le faire y compris je pense que dans les
médias interdire l'usage des images
construites à l'aide de connexion
pour les médias pour être sûr qu'il y en
a pas mais en vrai ça empêchera pas des
courants politiques d'en avoir l'usage
et donc là je pense que sur ces aspects
là il y a une nécessité de réguler mais
y compris les techniques je vais vous
donner un exemple c'est l'usage des
intelligences artificielles pour les
données biométriques
aujourd'hui c'est considéré si je me
trompe pas au niveau des discussions
actuelles comme étant un usage dangereux
mais il y a des exceptions qui risquent
d'être prévues notamment si c'est pour
prévenir des délits qui dans certains
pays serait
sanctionnable de au moins trois ans de
prison sauf que ça à partir vous avez
créé la technologie vous avez plus la
maîtrise de à quelle fin elle est
utilisée donc il y a d'abord la question
des usages qu'il faut voir mais il y a
aussi quelle technologie on accepte ou
on accepte pas et ensuite on pourra
jamais faire l'impasse de brider modérer
a priori même tenter de modérer a priori
les effets dangereux on considère que
c'est dangereux par exemple construire
pas forcément madame Melchior oui ça
tient parce que on a une liste des
usages qui sont interdits dans la
directive par exemple l'attaque
connexion biométrique des personnes en
temps réel de la distance donc votre
visage votre façon de parler votre façon
de marcher ça peut donner pour la police
les autorités ou même les entreprises la
possibilité de vous identifier et ça on
avait interdit dans le lois
de l'utiliser en temps réel la question
c'est aussi est-ce que la police doit
pouvoir reconnaître si vous êtes en
train de mentir en reconnaissant
émotionnelle moi je trouverais c'est une
chose qui entre interdire mais c'est pas
encore inclus dans le texte donc on a
cette
il y a deux méthodes dans le dans la loi
il y a les hauts risques les moyennes
risques les
classifications mais il y a aussi en
liste des utilisations qui sont bannis
donc
par exemple la police
prédictive pour
pour dire telle ou telle personne telle
était le quartier c'est il y a plus de
criminalités là-bas on a dit c'est en
utilisation que nous avons interdit là
où il y a les gros problèmes pour moi
pour l'utilisation de l'article
pour les propagandes c'est que il se
nécessitent qu'on est très critique et
sceptique sur l'utilisation parce qu'il
y a toujours des personnes des
mouvements politiques qui veulent nous
nous cacher les choses ou faire croire à
quelque chose et ça ça a des gros démons
pour nous comme société on n'avait pas
vraiment prévu en 2008 la situation en
2016 ou en 2023 sur les réseaux sociaux
précisément par exemple quand la Chine
qui est quand même un grand acteur
géopolitique dit que l'intelligence
artificielle devra refléter les valeurs
socialistes fondamentales on sent bien
que l'IA est en train de devenir un
instrument de guerre idéologique
d'aliénation je vous parlez de la Chine
effectivement c'est un vrai sujet mais
ça existe aussi dans nos démocraties
occidentales c'est-à-dire que
l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle que ce soit des fins
totalitaires dans des régimes
totalitaires pour contrôler la
population et la surveiller ou que ce
soit dans des régimes démocratiques pour
influencer le vote des citoyens et des
citoyens c'est un danger c'est les deux
phases d'une même pièce et d'un même
danger c'est derrière l'intelligence
artificielle il y a la captation des
données de nos données nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans un environnement
d'objets connectés d'interaction pour
nos achats dans nos vies qui génèrent
des milliards et des milliards de
données qu'est-ce que permet
l'interligence artificielle de les
collecter de les traiter et d'en tirer
des enseignements y compris ensuite pour
vous influencer dans vos votes et c'est
déjà arrivé ça a été au moment du brexit
avec Cambridge Analytica en
Grande-Bretagne c'était le cas dans les
élections américaines et ça va être le
cas dans nos élections en Europe où vous
captez les centres d'intérêts des
citoyens et vous allez cibler des
publicités électorales qui seront pas
forcément des fake news pour orienter
leur vote dans un sens ou dans l'autre
et c'est ça qu'il faut aussi préserver
au-delà de l'intelligence artificielle
il y a le protection du carburant
d'intelligence des données c'est un vrai
sujet vous en parlez alors il y a une
solution c'est d'interdire complètement
alors l'Italie a choisi parce qu'au sein
de l'Union européenne il y a des
réponses différentes italiens la
nouvelle version du logiciel
conversationnel
qu'il ne respectait pas la protection
des données l'interdiction est-ce que
c'est une bonne solution il faut avoir
des régulations des législations sur
l'utilisation des données et aussi
l'utilisation des intelligences
artificielle mais je trouve des juste à
te dire des nouvelles technologies parce
qu'ils sont nouvelles parce qu'on les
connaît pas c'est un peu les dernières
frontières politiques
il y a une fuite de données personnelles
quand même très très largement c'est
c'est inquiétant peut-être pour les
c'est très inquiétant et c'est aussi
inquiétant quand on avait vu clairview
qui ont utilisé des images de personnes
qui ont pas donné leur accord pour que
ces images sont été utilisées et donc il
faut avoir des des bornes il faut avoir
des des protections sur l'utilisation
des données quand c'est des données
personnelles quand c'est des données des
intellectuels des propriétés Antelle
aussi nous avons des projets législation
déjà sur les données industrielles et
nous avons déjà la protection sur les
données personnelles mais il faudra les
renforcer il faut ça aussi les renforcer
par la Commission européenne et aussi
les États membres et là je vois il y a
un danger qu'on ouvre la possibilité
pour les États membres des définir c'est
la sécurité nationale qui donne lieu à
l'utilisation des techniques qui ont été
dans les textes européennes interdits
parce que ça ouvre vraiment pour chaque
État membre d'utiliser cette technique
comme il veut alors pour éviter d'être
le ré il y a aussi un autre une autre
clause finalement l'Union européenne
veut mettre en place un garde-fou à
savoir un code couleur ou un symbole
pour signaler aux utilisateurs que ce
telle image telle information a été
générée par une intelligence
artificielle et ce que ça va suffire on
voit bien qu'on est en train de faire
dans un autre registre la chasse aux
fausses nouvelles sans vraiment les
rattraper toujours est-ce que là ça vous
paraît une bonne une bonne idée j'en
sais rien pourquoi pas mais là on est
vraiment en aval de la problématique
dont on parle moi je suis plutôt pour la
régulation et la réglementation en amont
parce que encore une fois je vous le
disais les gens qui ont envie de croire
un récit complotiste ou qu'il faut vous
pouvez le marquer comme vous voulez et
continueront à le croire donc je suis
pas je suis pas sûr malgré un code
couleur ça suffira pas contre le code
couleur mais enfin je crois qu'il faut
pas voir le sujet par c'est un petit peu
le bout de la gueule Ornex avec si vous
voulez c'est on s'inscrit dans un
contexte bien plus large y compris un
contexte géopolitique absolument majeur
au vincii siècle la question du contrôle
des données et de l'intelligence
artificielle ça sera l'équivalent de la
maîtrise des matières premières fossiles
à la fin du 19e et au 20e siècle c'est
ça dont on parle et pour l'Union
européenne c'est de construire une
identité économique politique et éthique
autour de cette technologie quelle est
notre identité quelles sont nos valeurs
à nous on voit ce qu'il en est en Chine
on voit ce qu'il en est aux États-Unis
en quoi nous proposons nous un modèle
différent qui soit pas comment dire dans
une forme défensive parce que peut y
avoir aussi une tentation de dire ah bah
nous on va être éthique ça on est pour
c'est très bien mais parce qu'on voit
qu'on sera en retard sur les autres on
peut pas se contenter d'une position
défensive faut une position offensive
constructive sur ses affaires et la
l'enjeu c'est la protection des droits
fondamentaux c'est les questions
éthiques fondamentales et c'est aussi
une forme d'autonomie stratégique et
géopolitique par rapport à ces grands
blocs aujourd'hui l'intelligence
artificielle c'est mieux traduire que
n'importe quel traducteur dessiner des
oeuvres originales sur commande ce n'est
plus seulement de métier pénible dont on
parle comme pour la robotique mais bien
de métier à haute valeur ajoutée qui
pourrait être détruit par elle il va
rester quoi aux humains finalement
l'exemple des interprètes ou les
traducteurs je suis pas convaincu
d'ailleurs les interprètes ici par
exemple Parlement par Anne à européen
ainsi sur le terme d'interprète et non
pas traducteur parce que nous abordons
des questions avec des enjeux qui sont
pas que technique politique et donc la
compréhension humaine qui peut permettre
d'avoir une interprétation qui soit la
plus fidèle je pense et pas facilement
mais là vous avez
par des millions d'exemples oui d'accord
mais y compris elle c'est en ça qu'elle
est en soi conservatrice parce qu'elle
s'appuie sur les données existantes et
donc elle est pas innovante dans le sens
où elle reproduit ce qui est la norme
sociale normée enfin voilà ce qui le
truc c'est y compris ça l'intelligence
humaine a une capacité d'extrapolation
de projection qui heureusement donc par
contre là vous avez raison c'est
pourquoi ces grands groupes concentrent
de telles investissements dans
l'intelligence artificielle c'est qu'il
soit de faire ce que vous décrivez c'est
à dire capter la valeur ajoutée et là il
y a une vision y compris post coloniale
impérialiste de la maîtrise de
l'intelligence artificielle pour aller
capter la fabrication l'intelligence
humaine construite par l'intelligence
artificielle donc y compris en termes de
protection du droit du travail
protection de la juste répartition des
profits lutte contre la concentration
des entreprises des lois antitrust ça
soulève aussi toutes ces questions là
les intelligences artificielles parce
que ça nécessite des investissements
colossaux que seuls d’immense groupes
vont pouvoir faire vous les réagir et ce
seront les mots de la fin c'est
justement parce qu'en les entraîne ces
technologies sur des données déjà il y a
des
il y a des paillasses il y a des
idées qui sont liées à la sélection des
données c'est pour ça que c'est très
important que on a un contrôle de
l'utilisation humain de cette
technologie parce que sinon ça peut
avoir des enjeux pour chacun des entre
nous pour notre santé pour notre droit
social comme on avait vu au Pays-Bas
merci à vous d'avoir très bien illustré
ce débat sur l'intelligence artificielle
vous restez sur nos antennes pour la
suite des programmes
[Musique]